bonjour à tous cet après midi les
sénateurs poursuivent ils espèrent finir
aujourd'hui l'examen du projet de loi
sur l'avenir de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation et de la forêt ce texte a
été adopté par l'assemblée nationale au
mois de janvier dernier et examiné en
première lecture au sénat alors ambition
principale de ces textes et bien verdir
l'agriculture mettre en place une
véritable agro écologie avec la création
de groupements d'intérêts économiques et
environnementales des groupements qui
rassemble les agriculteurs bonnes
pratiques qui en échange reçoivent des
aides préférentiels aujourd'hui les
sénateurs reprennent l'examen à
l'article 23 articles qui visent la
santé animale la santé végétale et plus
de sécurité sanitaire dans
l'alimentation
on est là plus particulièrement sur
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires en clair des pesticides
ont rejoint tout de suite l'hémicycle
les sénateurs ont plus de 200
amendements à examiner
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale d'avenir pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et la forêt
dans la discussion
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de priorité
sur un rôle sur le président
après
président en application de l'alinéa 6
de l'article 44 du règlement intérieur
je demande donc la priorité après
l'article 28 de l'article 33 terre à
merci monsieur le président donc j'ai
été saisie de cette demande de priorités
de la commission sur l'article donc 33
terre à afin qu'il soit examiné avant
l'article 29
c'est cela selon l'article 44 alinéa 6
de notre règlement mes chers collègues
la priorité de droit quand elle est
demandée par la commission saisie au
fond sauf opposition du gouvernement
donc monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du gouvernement sur cette demande
de priorité favorable merci monsieur le
ministre la priorité est donc ordonné
passionnant donc je rappelle quand même
que dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus aux amendements
identiques numéro 188 rectifié bis et
709 à l'article 23 donc des amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune amendement numéro 188 rectifié
bis monsieur l'abbé monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
si d'ici quelques années les
collectivités territoriales de même que
les particuliers pour leur jardin
domestique n'utiliseront plus de
pesticides pour l'entretien de leurs
espaces verts et jardins
rendons un service salutaire à la santé
de leurs administrés et concitoyens
ainsi qu'à la biodiversité
mais qu'en est-il en milieu péri urbain
ou rural là où les habitations touche
les champs aucune obligation n'existe
pour que les épandages de produits
chimiques
et dangereux se fasse à une certaine
distance de sécurité des habitations
c'est ce que nous proposons par cet
amendement donnant la possibilité au
préfet de mettre en place ses distances
de sécurité à l'instar du pouvoir qui
l'a déjà pour en faire de même à
proximité des zones humides ou d'autres
zones considérées comme vulnérables d'un
point de vue environnemental
ainsi on fait se rejoindre les
préoccupations en matière de santé
publique et de protection de
l'environnement
merci monsieur l'abbé l'amendement
numéro 709 madame bonne foi oui merci
monsieur le président donc l'article
l205 compte 3-7 du code rural donne la
possibilité à l'autorité administrative
de prendre dans l'intérêt de la santé
publique ou de l'environnement
certaines dispositions en matière
d'interdiction d'encadrement de
l'utilisation de produits
phytopharmaceutiques parmi ces
dispositions elle peut actuellement
interdire ou encadrer l'utilisation des
produits phytopharmaceutiques dans des
zones particulières telles des zones
utilisées par le grand public ou par des
groupes vulnérables les zones natura
2000 ou encore certaines zones protégées
le présent amendement vise à ajouter à
cette liste les zones à proximité des
habitations afin que soit prise en
compte la protection des riverains
merci madame bonne foi un amendement 456
rectifié bisbal boulet oui mais c'est le
président aussi le ministre cdh
amendements que j'ai cosigné avec
chantal jouanno qui cette fois ci vise
l'article l 253 alinéa 1 du code rural
s'agissant une fois encore comme les
deux autres amendements des produits
phytosanitaires il s'agit cette fois
d'interdire leur utilisation à moins de
100 mètres des propriétés à usage
d'habitation et des établissements
recevant du public
monsieur le rapporteur président
monsieur le ministre avis favorable pour
madame bonne foi et monsieur l'abbé
madame boulet je vous demanderais bien
de vous de le retirer au profit des deux
autres parce que le vôtre est plus
restrictif vous mettez une distance
alors qu autant laisser l'administration
à liberté de le faire les retirer merci
je les mets au voire même avis est ce
que je lui dise alors je l'aimais aux
voix qui est pour et qui est contre
ils sont adoptés le 190,8 rectifié bis
et le 709 bien sûr celui de madame
boulet et en retirer deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
toujours à l'article 23 l'amendement
numéro 36 rectifié terre qui est
présenté par mam prima merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
il s'agit ici de mieux encadrer la halle
à fort hood en tout cas de mieux de
mieux la sanctionner un meilleur
encadrement de l'utilisation des
produits phyto implique une lutte plus
efficiente contre les produits phyto
contrefaits et la diffusion de
substances non autorisées sur notre
territoire qui peuvent être à l'origine
de graves pathologies pour leurs
utilisateurs
je rajoute qu au cours de la mission
d'information sur les pesticides dont ma
bonne foi était était la rapporteure
nous avons eu des indications comme quoi
le le commerce on va dire de produits
non autorisés sur notre territoire ça
pouvait s'apparenter à au grand
banditisme et dans ce contexte il
convient d'harmoniser les sanctions
prévues à l'article l 253 tirek 15 du
code rural avec celles qui sont prévues
au premier alinéa de l'article l 521 10
du code de la propriété intellectuelle
qui stipule que lorsque les faits
portent sur des marchandises dangereuses
pour la santé la sécurité de l'homme ou
de l'animal les peines sont portées à 5
ans d'emprisonnement et à 500000 euros
d'amande
il s'agit donc d'un d'un amendement de
coordination entre les différents codes
dont je vous avais saisi monsieur le
ministre lors des questions cribles sur
la propriété intellectuelle merci madame
primeur
l'amendement numéro 710 et madame bonne
foi oui actuellement aucune sanction
n'est prévue dans le code rural en
matière de contrefaçon de fraude ou
d'importation illégale de produits
phytosanitaires
c'est bien évidemment un manque qu'il
faut combler si nous voulons vraiment
lutter contre ces pratiques
potentiellement très dangereuse tant
pour les agriculteurs que pour
l'environnement
donc le présent amendement vise à
définir les sanctions applicables dans
de pareils cas et nous proposons
d'aligner le niveau de sanction sur
celle proposée aux médicaments
vétérinaires à l'article 20 du présent
projet de loi
merci mais l'album fois monsieur le
rapporteur
merci il me semble que si nous votons
l'amendement de la bonne foi qu'ils ont
un avis favorable
votre amendement à qui je donne un avis
favorable mais satisfait parce que
madame bonne foi puisqu'il est plus
large donc si vous le retirer au profit
de celui ci maintenant parce qu'on part
on ne verra pas faire le contraire parce
que celui de madame bonne foi et plus
large sur retailleau à pardon oui le
gouvernement
sidérant monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président merci ben avi que le
rapporteur je rajoute un point dans le
plan ecophyto que nous avons mis en
place il ya un volet spécifique sur la
lutte contre la fraude contre les
importations frauduleuses et depuis que
nous avons adopté ce plan les contrôles
et l'administration travaille justement
pour chasser et poursuivre ceux qui sur
ces sujets la triche
merci monsieur le ministre sur otayo sur
le fond les deux amendements convergent
largement d'autant plus qu' il faut
avoir la main ferme
dès lors qu'il s'agit de molécules qui
sont dangereuses
avec la contracture alors nous on aurait
préféré bien sûr que l'amendement de
sophie primas prime si j'ose dire sur
l'excellent d'amendements de nicole
bonnefoy
on se ralliera la sagesse est ce que
vous me permettez de vous adresser mes
félicitations monsieur le président on
n'a pas pu participer au vote évidemment
mais je trouve qu'il ya deux qualités
vrai souligné dans l'hémicycle
si vous appartenez à une excellente
commission permanente du sénat je pense
pas que je sois daniel raoul qui me
contredise puis ensuite vous êtes
président de conseil général bien merci
monsieur retailleau madame madame prima
merci monsieur président oui je vais
évidemment retirer mon amendement profit
celui de nicole qui est plus plus larges
comme vous l'avez dit je voudrais juste
profité de l'occasion pour porte données
rendre hommage en fait à l'ensemble des
forces de douane de police qui
travaillent sur ces de justice qui
travaillent sur ces dossiers là parce
qu'ils ne sont pas très nombreux ils
font un travail remarquable
voilà je voulais simplement justifié
merci alors je mets aux voix la maman
710 qui est pour et qui est contre
donc il est adopté 5 amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'article 23 le 97 rectifié bis qui est
identique aux 481 madame prima merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc cet
amendement vise à supprimer la nier la
linea numéro 7
en fait cet alinéa exclu lui-même du
chant d'agrément tel qu'il est prévu à
l'article l 254 1 du code rural les
applicateurs en tant que prestataire de
services de produits de biocontrôle or
je trouve que cette dérogation nous
trouvons cette des goréens dérogation ne
se justifie pas dès lors que les
produits de biocontrôle c'est bénéfique
soit il par rapport aux produits
phytosanitaires peut-on supposer sont
quand même des produits ayant un effet
phyto et pour lesquels une évaluation
des risques et une autorisation de mise
sur le marché est nécessaire même si
elle doit être peut-être aller
et elle est nécessaire et ses produits
sont des produits qui ne sont pas
anodins pour la santé publique et pour
l'environnement
de plus et pour s'assurer d'un
développement et d'une mise en oeuvre
efficace du produit de biocontrôle il
convient de veiller à ce que leurs
applications soient effectués par des
prestataires dont les compétences sont
reconnues
en conséquence l'ensemble des règles qui
s'imposent aux produits phytosanitaires
doivent s'appliquer également aux
produits de biocontrôle même si je
conçois qu'il soit peut-être alléger
merci madame prima le 480 n'est pas
défendu un amendement 406 rectifié
madame fura merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'application de produits
phytosanitaires aux prestations de
services et subordonnés depuis le 1er
octobre 2013 à la certification de
l'entreprise prestataire
cette obligation a pour objectif de
sécuriser et si possible de diminuer
l'utilisation de ces produits sur les
territoires viticoles très morcelé il
est fréquent que des exploitants former
et équiper étendent leurs interventions
au traitement de parcelles voisines des
leurs dans le cadre de services qu'ils
ne peuvent être assimilés à de
l'entr'aide en l'absence de réciprocité
cette pratique garantit l'application
pertinentes et économe des produits
l'obligation faite aux exploitants
agricoles de faire certifier leurs
entreprises pour pau sud pour suivre la
réalisation de ses prestations à petite
échelle condamne cette pratique pour
l'avenir car la charge et des
contraintes de la procédure de
certification seront disproportionnée au
regard de la faible importance des
prestations en cause il s'ensuivra que
les bénéficiaires de ces prestations
devroe soit procéder eux mêmes à
l'application des produits au moyen de
matériel - évoluer soit faire appel à
des entreprises de prestations qui ne
pourront pas toujours intervenir au
moment le plus opportun et qui de ce
fait utiliseront de plus forte dose pour
assurer un minimum d'efficacité au
traitement afin d'éviter ces
conséquences contre-productive
au regard des finalités de la
certification il est proposé d'instituer
une dérogation à l'obligation de
certification pour ce que la prestation
réalisée
à titre accessoire par un exploitant
titulaire du certiphyto décideurs en
deçà d'un seuil fixé par décret qui
pourraient être exprimés soit en surface
par exemple deux hectares soit en
chiffre d'affaires par exemple 3000
euros l'homme fera le 257 rectifié terre
n'est pas défendu le 334 rectifié terre
monsieur césar
oui merci monsieur le président madame
ferrat vient de préciser l'amendement
que nous avions défendu ensemble et pour
moi c'est un amendement de précisions il
est important par rapport à ce qu'elle a
dit que justement que lorsque c'est un
titre secondaire qu'on puisse éviter le
fameux certiphyto merci monsieur césar
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président le mandement 97 de madame
prima je vais mettre un avis défavorable
parce que les poulets de biocontrôle
sont des procédés naturels sans danger
pour la santé publique et pour
l'environnement
il est non pas choquant de supprimer
l'obligation d'agrément pour ces pour
ses produits tout le monde s'accorde
aujourd'hui sur la nécessité de
développer l'utilisation de ces types de
produits la suppression de l'agrément me
sens pleinement cohérent avec cet
objectif
sur les deux autres qui sont un peu à
l'opposé madame ferrat le numéro 406 et
la dispense d'agrément pour les petits
applicateurs donc je ne suis pas
favorable
quant à monsieur césar il a dit lui-même
c'est un amendement de bon sens je
trouve seulement de bon sens mais j'ai
demandé l'avis du l'avis du gouvernement
merci comment je le crois c'est le bon
sens paysan
merci monsieur le rapporteur est
néanmoins président monsieur le ministre
mes propres premier premier point sur le
biocontrôle l'agrément il y aura une
liste qui sera publiée par décret pour
que toutes les matières du bio contrôles
qui seront justement exonérés de cet
agrément soit effectivement parfaitement
compatible avec un usage sans agrément
pour certaines il ya peut-être des
matières actives qui seront plus
dangereuse à ce moment là il y aura
nécessité d'agrément mais l'idée comme
l'a dit le rapporteur
c'est de favoriser l'utilisation des
produits de biocontrôle donc essayons
d'être le plus souple possible tout en
étant extrêmement rigoureux donc la
liste décret dans le décret publiera les
différentes matières actives celles qui
sont sans danger et bien elle passe en a
grand celles qui ont des dangers bien
sûr ne sont pas dans cette liste et donc
nécessiteront agrément après vous avez
deux amendements qui visent à caen en
direct exonérés du certiphyto les
petites exploitations en gros c'est ça
là je ne suis pas d'accord pour une
raison simple certiphyto c'est une
formation j'ai donné est délivré pour
utiliser les produits phytosanitaires
pour éviter les dangers qu'ils sont liés
à l'utilisation de ces produits qui sont
comme vous le savez dangereux vin de
bonne foi mêmes primes avait fait un
rapport il ya eu suffisamment de cas
avérés et quelquefois dramatique pour
que cette formation puisse être
dispensés à tous ceux qui utilisent ses
produits
on va pas exposé parce qu'on a une
petite exploitation plus quelqu'un que
quelqu'un qui aurait une grande
exploitation donc là je suis pas
favorable à ces deux amendements
voilà merci monsieur le ministre alors
sur le 97 rectifié bis oui à l'isi
merci monsieur le président où je
souhaiterais revenir sur le 406 monsieur
le ministre la fin de mon propos est
celui ci il est proposé d'instituer une
dérogation à l'obligation de
certification d'entreprise lorsque la
prestation est réalisé à titre
accessoire par un exploitant titulaire
du certiphyto décideurs donc il ya déjà
quelque part une validation de
compétences et de capacités
on n'est pas tout à fait dans l'esprit
de laisser-faire des traitements par des
personnes qui n'auraient pas une base
solide de deux produits
merci zimmer collègues
oui monsieur le président pour appuyer
l'amendement de françoise férat parce
que je crois que il faut trouver à la
fois des précautions principe de
précaution n'est pas rebuté l'innovation
principe d'innovation par rapport au
principe de précaution est de plus en
plus et les tests qui ceux qui se
défendent et qui mérite d'être
accompagné sur le plan législatif et là
c'est une amende mans tout à fait
pragmatique qui respecte à la fois le
danger de ces produits phytosanitaires
qui sont nocifs pour la santé pour un
certain nombre ne l'oublions pas il
s'agit de passer à l'acte et qui ne vont
pas à l'encontre de l'innovation qui là
aussi sera dans ce domaine là tout à
fait essentiel pour à la fois amené une
production respectant l'environnement et
assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
donc je pense que c'est un amendement
particulièrement pragmatique c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur le plan du
département nous sommes nombreux à
soutenir ce type d'avancé législatif
trouvant un juste compromis entre ces
produits finis vos sanitaires et on en
reparlera au cours d'un autre amendement
les briauds du broc console ou les pnpp
alors je mets aux voileux 97 rectifié
bis
monsieur ministre rapidement sur cette
question j'ai bien compris les arguments
je peux admettre un principe de sagesse
sur cette question on verra en deuxième
lecture parce qu'il faut quand même bien
qu'on soit clair on ne peut pas laisser
passer sur ces questions là ddd qu'en
dirait jeter des éléments qui remettra
en cause la logique générale surtout sur
certiphyto mais j'ai compris ça tangue
d'argonne d'arguments particulier sur un
prestataire qui serait lui qui aurait eu
le certificat certiphyto qui viendrait
chez un petit agriculteur
bon on voit bien mais j'accepte sagesse
on regardera ça sur la deuxième lecture
pour être sûr que dans ce sujet là on
n'ouvre pas des portes avec des risques
derrière madame pris ma wii simulez je
trouve un peu con tradicteur finalement
votre position parce que sur
l'amendement que je défends il s'agit de
prendre des précautions j'ai bien
compris que vous auriez un décret avec
une liste précise de produits mais dans
cet amendement il s'agit de prendre des
précautions sur la mise sur le marché de
produits de biocontrôle alors et vous ne
souhaitez pas qu'on le fasse par esprit
de simplification et l'amendement notre
collègue ferrat est elle un peu plus
j'allais dire facilitatrice pour des
personnes de qui qui ont déjà qu'ils
sont déjà qu'ils sont déjà certifiés et
là là vous vous bloquez donc où vous
semblez bloqué de 15 ans qu'il ya une
contradiction entre les deux mois
voulant prendre des précautions avant la
mise sur le marché alors que ma collègue
ferrat voudrait prendre un peu plus de
liberté avec des personnes qui sont déjà
formés donc voilà je trouve qu'il ya un
peu de nos contradictions entre les deux
monsieur le ministre j'ai même avis sur
les deux amendements 1 406 et 334 voilà
parce que les bons sauts sur les deux
amendements qu'elle est le problème que
vous posez c'est que vous voulez
maintenir un agrément sur les produits
bio contrôle iliad a lutte intégrée par
exemple les coccinelles et autres ont
pas donné d agrément sur des sujets
comme ça on fera des d un décret qui
donnera des autorisations pour une
certaine liste qui n'a pas de danger si
on considère que des matières actives
dans le cadre du bio contrôle août à
l'envié sont là il y aura la nécessité
d'avoir un agrément mais simplifiant la
procédure
si on veut que ça se développe si on
veut des agriculteurs utilisent ces
nouveaux produits pour justement éviter
d'utiliser les phytosanitaires
traditionnel et bien ouvrons un peu et
donnant de la souplesse c'est tout mais
je suis parfaitement cohérent sous les
deux amendements
merci monsieur va porter à aa après ce
débat gmi j'émets un avis défavorable
sur celui de madame ferrals madame
primal un avis favorable sur celui de
monsieur césar ou là
bien ça se complique donc monsieur le
ministre vous êtes favorable aux 406 aux
334 c'est cela oui
et monsieur le rapporteur vous êtes
favorable aux 334 est défavorable aux
deux autres biens je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement numéro 97 rectifié bis qui
est pur il retirer le 406 rectifié qui
est pour
contre
et les rejeter et l'amendement numéro 3
134 extractif y&r qui est pour et qui
est contre bien il est adopté
monsieur césar un amendement numéro 74
rectifié bis qui est défendue par le
primat merci monsieur le président donc
cet amendement vise à rendre plus
efficient le conseil spécifique à
l'utilisation des produits phyto et à
revoir la rédaction actuelle d'un art de
l'article 254 et 7 du code rural de la
pêche en prévoyant la mention soit de la
substance active soit de la spécialité
commercial l'objectif est de simplifier
la fiche de préconisations afin de la
rendre plus lisible pour l'agriculteur
en effet selon le type de culture il est
plus pertinent de préconiser des
matières actives
lorsque celles ci sont communes où le
nom commercial par ailleurs les
organismes réalisant du conseil
indépendants doivent avoir la
possibilité d'indiquer sur la fiche de
préconisation seulement la substance
active et non une seule spécialité
commerciale afin de préserver leurs
seins percés impartialité pardonnez moi
en outre afin de garantir la
communication de l'intégralité des
informations il est également proposé
qu'un document complémentaire aux fiches
de préconisations reprenant de façon
exhaustive l'ensemble des spécialités et
leurs substances actives préconisée par
les conseillers la réglementation liée à
l'utilisation des produits phyto soit
remis à minima annuellement à chaque
agriculteur ayant bénéficié d'un conseil
et en remplaçant enfin la notion de
parcelles et leurs superficies par le
périmètre à traiter dans le cadre du
conseil individuel l'identification du
nom de la parcelle et de la superficie
ne sont bien souvent pas adaptées car il
peut s'agir de traiter par exemple une
partie de parcelle un ensemble de
parcelles ou une culture sous serre ou
telle variété de végétal à tel stade la
notion de périmètre à traiter se
révélerait par conséquent à notre avis
plus pertinente
merci même prime à monsieur le
rapporteur président cette préconisation
écrite devrait ainsi désormais présida
substances actives ou la spécialité
recommandé et non plus ces deux éléments
c'est le sens de votre amendement cet
assouplissement me semble-t-il n'est pas
conforme du aux objectifs du grenelle de
l'environnement aussi j'y suis
défavorable
si monsieur le ministre même avis et par
rapport à toutes ces questions liées au
conseil pour les agriculteurs sur
l'utilisation des phytosanitaires ou
autres produits
il faut qu'ils aient l'information
qu'ils soient donnés il faut qu'il ait
une information qu'ils soient donnés
aussi sur les méthodes alternatives et
donc ce qui existe aujourd'hui qui a été
décidé dans le cadre du grenelle de
l'environnement doit rester c'est pour
ça que je ne suis pas favorable à votre
amendement madame prima merci monsieur
ministre 20 prime à leurs explications
de vote
oui pardonnez-moi veut ça vient en fait
renforcer les informations qui sont
aujourd'hui donnée et puis ce n'est pas
la seule le seul contenu de cet
amendement puisque l'on parle également
du du périmètre de l'application pardon
du périmètre à traiter et non des
parcelles leurs superficies donc moi je
veux bien sous-amendé mais il ya
plusieurs éléments dans cet amendement
peut-être faut-il les séparer merci ben
prima je le mets aux voix 74 rectifié
bis avis défavorable de la commission
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté deux amendements et
un sous amendement à l'article 23
l'amendement numéro 665 rectifié
monsieur césar
oui merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement rédactionnelle parce que
j'ajoute d'un entraînement au moins une
fois par an c'est le conseil qui donnait
par les utilisateurs par les
distributeurs
et c'est un pari important par rapport
aux textes qui proposait alinéa 17
d'ajouter au moins les conseils sont
faits sont donnés une fois par an
conseils individualisés bien sûr c'est
ça la précision que je voulais apporter
par rapport donc la rédaction d'aligner
à 17 du projet de loi un amendement 796
monsieur le rapporteur le président
c'est vrai qu'en commission un
amendement qui rendait le texte un peu
compliqué donc j'attendrai mon avis tu
as l'air sur celui de monsieur de
monsieur césar sur lequel j'ai pas de
problème et donc la commission a
souhaité réécrire l'allègement de
l'obligation de conseil pour les achats
récurrents
je vais donc simplement vous lire
l'argumentation qui réécrit
l'ensemble du dispositif le projet de
loi met en place donc une obligation de
conseil individualisé vivement vivant
visant à encourager les pratiques
alternatives pour les distributeurs de
produits phytopharmaceutiques
cela va dans le bon sens et
responsabilise le vendeur dans
l'évolution des pratiques mais la
rédaction d'articles 23 étaient
difficilement opérationnel pause achats
récurrents
on n'allait pas demander à chaque fois
d'avoir le d'avoir le conseil aussi
l'amendement que nous avons rédigé en
commission précise de quelle manière le
conseil doit être prodigués par les
distributeurs des produits
phytopharmaceutiques
il faut que le client bénéficie donc
comme viennent de le dire excellemment
monsieur césar au moins une fois par an
mais pas à chaque fois d'un conseil
individualisé pour ses achats récurrents
ils sont on parle bien des achats
récurrents lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
récurrents c'est une autre procédure
donc une fois par an au lieu de à chaque
à chaque achat et 7
cet amendement que nous avions que nous
avions réécrit pour écrire l'article 23
comprend l'amendement de monsieur césar
on avait considéré qu'il allait un peu
plus loin enfin nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure à porter un sous-amendement
numéro 852 qui présentait permanent
bonne foi oui dans la droite ligne de ce
que vient de dire monsieur le rapporteur
pour écarter tout malentendu il convient
de réaffirmer le principe général posé
jusqu alors dans le projet de loi à
savoir l'obligation de délivrance par
les distributeurs dont conseils
individualisés aux acheteurs la
dérogation à ce principe doit rester
l'exception
laquelle est toutefois compréhensible
lorsqu'il s'agit de produits que les
utilisations des utilisateurs achètent
fréquemment dans ces cas précis le
conseil peut être délivré qu'une fois
par par an donc il convient de rédiger
dans les cas où elle distribue des
produits phytosanitaires à un client
effectuant des achats récurrents du même
produit phytopharmaceutique ce conseil
peut être formulée qu'une fois par an
leurs achats récurrents récurrents
n'étant pas dans le texte
merci même bonne foi alors monsieur le
rapporteur
si à madame bonne foi bon je lui mets
ton avis favorable récurrents et bien en
texte n'était pas dans le texte initial
mais dans le texte prévu d'amendements
que je vous propose de voter que j'ai
présenté au nom de la non de la
commission mais bon ce quelques
précisions rédactionnelle j'ai pas
d'avis négatifs sur le sujet
quant à monsieur césar vous faites comme
vous voulez monsieur césar je considère
qu'il est satisfait j'y suis favorable
évidemment mais il est très proche de
suivre nous avons voté en commission qui
est un peu plus large donc si vous le
retirer votre amendement toute façon est
satisfait
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
césar le président est revenu satisfait
la proposition de monsieur clients dont
copie ce que mon amendement satisfait je
le suis aussi je le retire
merci profit du rail au profit de
l'amendement du rapporteur d'accord
proposition du rapporteur qui a été
approuvé par la commission
merci pour ces précisions
donc je mets aux voix le sous-amendement
852 qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté et l'amendement numéro 7
196 qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté un amendement 220 rectifié
bis qu'il défend je savary oui merci
monsieur le président cet amendement
porte sur l'autorité administratif en ce
qui concerne effectivement ces
différents produits notamment les
phytosanitaires où il est demandé de les
transférer au niveau du ministère chargé
des affaires sociales de la santé de
l'écologie pour avoir des déserts et
même du fait des répercussions sur la
santé
c'était là aussi un amendement pour que
vous puissiez nous donner votre avis sur
cette proposition
davari monsieur le rapporteur président
cet amendement va totalement à
l'encontre de ce que nous avons voté
hier soir et l'article 22 le transfert à
lens est ce donc je ne peux pas donner
un avis un avis favorable que hier soir
nous avons eu un long débat très longs
débats même sur la l'article 22 et après
explications la haute assemblée a voté
l'article 22 suivent en cela les
recommandations les arguments et les
explications du ministre
donc c'est en transition avec l'article
22 donc défavorable ce ministre mais ma
vie puisque le débat
vous y étiez le seul président a été
suffisamment long et approfondi et puis
deuxièmement jeu même si on n'avait pas
eu ce débat et si on n'avait pas adopté
ce que nous avons adoptée je le dis
quand même
transféré cet amendement vise à
transférer donc ces salles autorité
administrative la délivrance des
décisions des mêmes de produits phytos
phyto pharmaceutique au ministère chargé
de la santé de l'écologie sur les
questions qui concernent l'agriculture
ça aurait sûrement été un objet de débat
monsieur visée parce que c'est quand
même assez radicales comme sont donc on
a voté hier que lens s avaient des
responsabilités et maintenant je pense
que c'est mieux comme ça
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
savary pour explication de vote
merci mais je retire mon amendement si
monsieur savary deux amendements
identiques un article 23 le 168 monsieur
l'abbé oui ce n'est pas pour le plaisir
de n'être jamais content on recherche
les alternatives aux pesticides et les
maquereaux organismes en font partie
tout comme les préparations naturelles
peu préoccupantes
alors que l'on demande aux pauvres aux
préparations naturelles peu
préoccupantes des procédures d'analysé
du risque
on en a parlé hier soir qui sont lourdes
pour les maquereaux organisme on nous
propose de ne pas de ne pas avoir besoin
de les évaluer et cela peut conduire ils
sont souvent importés et cela peut
conduire à des déséquilibres écologiques
majeurs car le confinement n'est pas
toujours efficace à 100% par cet
amendement il s'agit de réintroduire
l'évaluation des risques en situation
confine et de confier l'autorisation
ministère de l'agriculture et non au
seul préfet merci monsieur l'abbé 1 221
rectifié qui est présentée par monsieur
savary un même type d'amendements là
aussi nous sommes permis de le poser
pour avoir votre vision par rapport aux
rapports économie et écologie à travers
ce problème des macros organismes savary
monsieur le rapporteur
je pense que le ministre vous donnera
son avis vous éclairera le moi je ne
suis pas favorable la suppression de
l'assouplissement des obligations en cas
d'introduction sur le territoire de
maquereaux organisme destiné à une
utilisation confinée
il s'agit de développer
l'expérimentation de techniques
alternatives de protection des cultures
une autorisation reste cependant
nécessaire elle est donnée par le préfet
de région qui précisera les mesures de
confinement nécessaire donc monsieur
l'abbé monsieur savary propose de
revenir cet assouplissement je propose
que nous restions souple et je donne
deux avis défavorables
merci monsieur n'importera monsieur le
ministre bon on a une autorisation qui
donnait pas le préfet donc c'est pas
comme si il n'y avait pas un contrôle
qui était fait deuxièmement avec les
maquereaux organisme on est dans des
systèmes qu'on connaît bien de lutte
intégrée
on est dans un milieu confiné donc on
cherche simplement avec cet amendement à
assouplir les décisions qui peuvent être
prises par des exploitants de serre et
autres outils de production pour que
cette lutte intégrée ces luttes avec
l'utilisation des micro-organismes juste
être facilitée mais il ya toujours une
autorisation qui est donnée par le
préfet donc on n'est pas du tout dans un
système où il y aurait aucun contrôle
voilà donc là-dessus il n'y a pas de
sujet d'inquiétude à avoir a lâché
visiter ya pas très longtemps en
bretagne tout une nouvelle serre qui
avait été mise en place d'une grande
entreprise bien connue qui s'appelle je
ne dirait pas son nom
d'ailleurs mais qui a développé
justement tous les maquereaux organismes
nécessaires à une lutte intégrée
nouvelle toute la question des
pollinisation et des pollinisateurs sur
les tomates en particulier avec des
bourdons tout ça ça se fait dans le
manière confiné et c'est extrêmement
important de développer ce type de
projet le tout étant je le dis toute
façon soumis à autorisation du préfet
merci monsieur le ministre
alors je mets aux voix ces deux
amendements identiques qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient
ils ne sont pas adopté deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
un numéro 711 madame bonne foi oui
l'article l 211-3 du code de
l'environnement précise qu'en complément
des règles générales de gestion
équilibrée durable de la ressource
anneaux en france des prescriptions
particulières à certaines parties du
territoire peuvent être fixées par
décret en conseil d'état
dans cette optique il prévoit la
possibilité pour l'autorité
administrative dans des conditions
fixées par décret de délimiter des
programmes d'action à l'intérieur des
zones où il est nécessaire d'assurer la
protection quantitative et qualitative
des aires d'alimentation des captages
d'eau potable d'une importance
particulière pour l'approvisionnement
actuels ou futurs
le présent amendement vise à préciser
clairement que ce type de programme peut
prévoir l'interdiction de l'usagé de
substances dangereuses pour la santé ou
l'environnement dans ces zones cette
proposition s'intègre bien dans les
objectifs fixés par le gouvernement dans
le cadre de la conférence
environnementale d'identification 2000
captages prioritaires incluant le
développement d'une agriculture
respectueuse de l'environnement afin de
garantir la qualité de la ressource en
eau merci ma bonne foi le 169 monsieur
l'abbé il est défendu sur la porter
favorable qui a répondu qu'il était
défendue sur un jeu tenait sur cet
amendement à en rajouter une petite
couche
cet amendement touche une nouvelle fois
la réduction de l'usagé des pesticides
en zones agricoles
il s'agit de protéger les périmètres de
captage de nombreuses collectivités ont
déjà engagé des actions exemplaires avec
le milieu agricole les effets bénéfiques
ne concerne pas que la préservation de
la ressource et la santé ils sont
également économiques de part les
économies réalisées en termes de
traitement des eaux pour les services
d'alimentation en eau potable
le coût du préventif est toujours
inférieur au coût du curatif et parfois
très inférieurs les coûts de
potabilisation de l'eau induit par les
pollutions émises par l'agriculture
conventionnelle se situe dans une
fourchette entre 8 cents à 2400 euros
par hectare et par an
quant aux pesticides
6000 euros le kilo d'estimé pour pour
l'élimination des pesticides dans l'eau
par ailleurs 400 captage ont été
abandonnés chaque année en classe entre
98 et 2008 et je vais en terminer par
l'avis du cse dans son rapport sur la
gestion et les usages de l'eau en
agriculture qui en appelle à une sortie
rapide sur ces parcelles de
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires de synthèse
alors encore une fois il s'agit de
donner raison à des pratiques beaucoup
d'entre nous avons initié sur nos
territoires en lien avec les
agriculteurs et leurs organisations et
en faisant de ces territoires des
territoires exemplaire en termes
d'agroécologie jeu la baie sur la porter
favorable poursuivi madame bonne foi
retrait car satisfait pour monsieur
l'abbé merci monsieur ministre sur
suivant une bonne foi principe qui
consiste à dire on interdit les
substances dangereuses dans les zones de
captage principe qui est tout à fait
acceptable sauf que quand on dit
substances dangereuses
la liste elle est très longue et donc on
a un problème quand même de deux
définitions
c'est un vrai sujet donc moi je veux
bien dire sagesse sur cette question
mais on va bien y regarder à deux fois
d'ici la deuxième lecture parce qu'il
faut qu'on regarde exactement ce que ça
a comme conséquence sur monsieur l'abbé
le fait qu'on interdirait tout
substances phytosanitaires à l'exception
des biocontrôle sûr très compliqué parce
que même certains pnpp pourraient être
interdits l'un et dans la lecture
biologique il ya des utilisations des
phytosanitaires
donc là c'est pareil une fois qu'on met
un art un article comme ça de loi on
pense qu'on a à régler beaucoup de
problèmes mais derrière ça des
conséquences je rappelle que dans
l'agriculture bio jus du biologique il
ya certains phytosanitaires sont
utilisés même des pnpp sont considérés
comme des produits phytosanitaires donc
tels que c'est écrit là c'est pas
possible donc je suis défavorable donc
sagesse sur celui d'un bonne foi parce
qu'il y avait une vraie question c'est
des substances dangereuses
c'est quoi s'il faut les interdire de
quoi on parle et sur l'amendement de
monsieur l'abbé
les conséquences de cette interdiction
stricte elle serait tel que ça poserait
d'énormes problèmes donc je peux pas
être favorable
merci monsieur le ministre explications
de vote monsieur l'abbé non je ne veux
surtout pas être intégriste et pour
donner plus de force parce que je ne le
suis pas et pour donner plus de force à
l'amendement de nicole bonnefoy
on retire le nôtre on se range sur celui
de nicole bonnefoy monsieur ses arcs
pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le président mais je
voulais intervenir après l'amendement de
monsieur l'abbé mais comme il a retiré
c'est très difficile mais que dire que
les périmètres par rapport aux stations
de pompage existe déjà et c'est le
préfet qui prend qui prend la décision
par un arrêté préfectoral et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les précautions sont
suffisantes c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter une couche alors sur le 711 de
madame bonne foi qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté je fais voté l'article 23
qui même vote même vote
l'article 3 bis même vote même vote à
l'article 24
j'ai une demande de parole de monsieur
le noir oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons eu un long débat en
commission des affaires économiques sur
l'article 24 et sur l'opportunité de
légiférer par ordonnance
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire au nom de mon
groupe que nous étions tout à fait
défavorable sur le principe de cette
initiative qui a été prise par le
gouvernement
nous avons entendu monsieur le
rapporteur en commission nous expliquer
que lorsque la droite était au pouvoir
elle n'avait pas manqué de proposer des
ordonnances c'est vrai on ne peut pas
réécrire l'histoire
toutefois nous avons encore dans les
oreilles
les arguments très percutant que nous
avons entendu venant de la partie gauche
de l'hémicycle aussi bien au sénat que
pour certains d'entre nous à l'assemblée
nationale des arguments pertinents qui
des conseillers
de légiférer par ordonnances et notre
position aujourd'hui est tout à fait
hostile à l'article 24 du reste biologie
de tweed nous serons amené tout à
l'heure a voté un amendement que notre
collègue monsieur le cam a déposée
visant à supprimer cet article alors
j'ajoute que lorsque l'on regarde
l'article 24 tel qu'il nous est proposé
il y à des dispositions qui figureraient
dans une ordonnance et qui sont assez
voisines de celles qui ont été discutés
à l'article 23
je n'entre pas dans le détail mais vous
nous proposez d'intervenir dans des
domaines tout à fait voisins
ce ne sont pas des domaines négligeable
ce ne sont pas des domaines et que nous
devons passer sous silence
quand bien même nous aurions la
possibilité dans le cadre de
l'habilitation de ces ordonnances d'en
rediscuter
il s'agit par exemple de l'utilisation
des produits phytopharmaceutiques
il s'agirait également de moderniser et
de simplifier les règles applicables aux
matières fertilisantes et supports de
culture g en parlais tout à l'heure
modifiez simplifier le régime applicable
aux groupements de défense que nous
connaissons bien sur nos territoires et
qui joue un rôle très important et là
dessus nous souhaiterions pouvoir
connaître dès à présent quelles sont les
intentions du gouvernement
il y a également l'organisation est en
fait il est dit redéfinir et modernisé
mais dans quel sens et sous quelle forme
l'émission de l'ordre des vétérinaires
là aussi ces professions se tournent
vers nous en nous disant mais de quoi
s'agit-il
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement dans ce domaine
il y également alors une disposition qui
franchement ne trouve pas sa place dans
nos préoccupations
du moins c'est mon avis il s'agit des
règles applicables au commerce des
animaux de compagnie franchement
aujourd'hui est ce que nous avons à nous
pencher sur cette question ô combien
estimable quand on connaît toutes les
dispositions qui sont mises à la
disposition aussi bien des collectivités
des associations de défense des animaux
et qui aujourd'hui est vite qu'il y ait
des abus et s'il y en a il relève de la
loi et j'estime que tout cela fonctionne
suffisamment bien pour ne pas donner
l'impression aux personnes qui
s'intéressent à ces animaux domestiques
au va encore alourdir les dispositions
de la loi
enfin il ya monsieur le ministre un
autre point c'est le septième mans de
l'article 24 adapté au droit de l'union
européenne les dispositions relatives au
transport des animaux vivants et aux
sous produits animaux notamment en
redéfinissant l'activité d'équarrissage
en actualisant et en complétant la liste
des sanctions etc
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible
nous avons eu à le connaître il ya
presque vingt ans à propos de la crise
de la vache folle il y a eu des textes
importants qui ont été soumis à
l'approbation du parlement qui ont donné
lieu à la loi de 1996
nous ne pouvons pas au moment où il a
été dit dans la presse qu'un non lieu
était prescrit sur ce scandale de la
vache folle nous ne pouvons pas donner
l'impression que par voie d'ordonnancé
nous allons aborder un sujet qui
intéresse très directement nos
concitoyens voilà les raisons pour
lesquelles monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
nous estimons que les points qui mérite
d'être regardée doivent être introduits
dans la loi que certains sont inutiles
de lady pour le commerce des petits
animaux et donc que le parlement soit
amené à en discuter très directement
merci monsieur noir monsieur ministre
bon je voulais juste préciser une chose
c'est que ces ordonnances pour qu'on
soit transparent sont disponibles ce
soir et sont distribués aux fans lors de
lens sera distribué ce soir dans ses
grandes lignes aux représentants des
chefs de groupe
donc chacun pour avoir connaissance de
ce qu'il ya dedans et on évitera comme
ça
après la discussion de l'article 24 bien
sûr mais quand même il n'y a rien à
cacher vous avez parlé d'un certain
nombre de choses
la directive transport des animaux je
vous le dis ça c'est une directive qui
s'applique directement en droit national
et qui fait pas l'objet de discussions
si j'avais la possibilité de discuter
des règles d'application on pourrait le
faire mais ça c'est pas possible
sur le premier aussi article dans ces
ambiances sur les questions liées à
l'expérimentation sur les produits
phytopharmaceutiques c'est
l'expérimentation tout à fait possible
et donc ça c'est des règles qu'on mettra
pour ordonnance c'est tous ces sujets
qui sont qui relève de l' ordonnance
sans qu'il y ait d'ailleurs je le dis
puisque on vous le distribuera de
problèmes de choses qui seraient comment
dirais-je qui viendrait remettre en
cause le débat nécessaire au niveau du
parlement le débat a lieu dans les
articles législatifs quand il est du
domaine législatif là on est dans le
domaine purement de l'ordonance vraiment
soyez le touch rassuré et je le dis
d'autant plus que ce soir après la pause
de 19h30 donc à 21h30 distribuera à tous
les chefs de groupe les les lignes que
j'ai là des ordonnances voilà merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur président le parlement est
toujours rétifs aux ordonnances si la
question à quoi sert le parlement cilia
pas d'ordonnancé est là le ministre
propose 8 ordonnance et l'opposition est
dans son rôle de dire vous devriez pas à
légiférer par ordonnances et il ya
quelques années en arrière quand bruno
le maire a présenté la lm ap il avait 16
ordonnance je suppose que vous avez
soutenu et louis et je suppose que
l'opposition d'alors dans laquelle
j'étais a dû dire non il ya trop de
ordonnance dont chacun est dans son rôle
tantôt ce sont les uns tantôt ce sont
les autres le ministre fait la
transparence en nous les présentons je
propose que nous passions aux
amendements
bien passons à l'amendement 628 qui est
présentée par monsieur le cam
c'est le président seul ministe chers
collègues
c'est notre première intervention cet
après midi je voudrais donc en profiter
pour féliciter monsieur didier guillaume
pour sa brillante élection en tant que
président du groupe socialiste
par ailleurs pour ce qui concerne cet
amendement de suppression lié bien sûr
vous l'avez compris par les ordonnances
dont le grand défaut et le en général de
ne pas savoir exactement ce qu'il en
sera fait j'ai bien entendu ne prône la
proposition de monsieur le ministre nous
les faire connaître dans la journée
nous ne voulons pas non plus privé cet
hémicycle du débat sur le contenu même
de cet article donc nous allons retirer
le 620 3 amendements donc faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune à
l'article 24 le 222e rectifié qui est
présentée par monsieur savary dans ce
cadre heure-là et de l'expérimentation
notamment des produits phytosanitaires
on se pose également la question de
l'application des principes
d'application de l'expérimentation de
ces produits là c'est en tout cas le but
de l'amendement jeu sauvagerie 1 455
rectifié mam goulet oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues s'agit d'un amendement très
simple puisqu'il s'agit de remplacer le
mot expérimentation par les mots un plan
d'action en effet les expérimentations
ayant eu lieu il faut maintenant mettre
en place un plan d'action de réduction
des produits phytopharmaceutiques donc
il s'agit juste de remplacer un mot par
un autre merci en 629 présentée par
monsieur le câble oui ce président ce
mini chers collègues parmi les chants
d'habilitation l'article 24 propose de
mettre en place une expérimentation
ayant pour objet de réduire
l'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques en définissant les
personnes vendant des produits
phytopharmaceutiques autant autre que
les produits de biocontrôle qui sont
tenus de mettre en oeuvre les actes et
actions à cette fin les conditions dans
lesquelles ces personnes peuvent
satisfaire à ses obligations et un
dispositif de certificats d'économies de
produits phytopharmaceutiques qui sont
délivrés aux personnes assujetties
lorsqu elle justifie avoir satisfaire
leurs obligations
ou dont l'acquisition leur permet de se
libérer de ses obligations il s'agit là
comme l'avait fait à l'époque la droite
avec le marché de certificats d'économie
d'énergie de permettre à ceux qui ont
les moyens financiers de déroger aux
règles et objectifs de réduction de
l'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques
un tel système risque de remettre
l'efficacité même de la réglementation
vise et surtout si le prix du certificat
est fixé très bas c'est pourquoi nous
vous demandons d'adopter cet amendement
629 merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le président donc sur les
ordonnances toujours ils habitent les
habilite le gouvernement à mettre en
place une expérimentation ayant pour
objet de réduire l'utilisation des
produits phyto marquée notamment par un
dispositif des certificats d'économies
de produits phytopharmaceutiques
s'inspirant du dispositif des
certificats d'économies d'énergie
la mise en place de tels certificats a
été recommandé par le cg à cg 2 1 er par
le cgedd et par l'inspection générale
des finances le conseil général de
l'alimentation pour l'agriculture etc
vous connaissez par coeur conseil
général de l'environnement de
développement durable et l'inspection
des finances
c'est plus clair le projet de loi
prévoit dans un premier temps une
expérimentation de ce dispositif dont
les modalités sont définies par cette
ordonnance est donc je pense qu'il faut
y être favorables à ce qu'il ya dans le
dans le texte c'est la raison pour
laquelle je donne des avis défavorable
aux amendements 222 455 et 629 voilà
pour l'examen de ce projet de loi sur
l'avenir de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation et de la forêt un texte
qui a essentiellement pour ambition de
mettre en place une véritable agro
écologie est de verdir l'agriculture
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours retrouver
toutes les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 19h pour 24
ans n'a présenté par jérôme rabier très
bonne fin de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires